un carpintero está usando un torno para
darle forma final a la pata de una mesa
que está hecha a mano y realmente en
torno si podemos recordar es una cosa
que gira y que es una máquina que
utilizan mucho los carpinteros
justamente para darle formas cilíndricas
a por ejemplo la pata de una mesa ahora
para lograr que en bone necesita ser de
150 milímetros de ancho permitiéndole un
margen de error un margen de error de
2.5 milímetros y es que en la práctica
pues aunque uno desee que la pata sea de
150 milímetros de ancho pues siempre
ocurren errores errores humanos errores
de precisión qué sé yo y lo que sí nos
dice es que bueno uno puede tener un
error pero que no pase de 2.5 milímetros
es decir que el ancho de nuestra pata no
sea más de él
el ancho esperado por 2.5 ni tampoco
menos escribe una desigualdad con valor
absoluto que modele esta relación y
luego encuentra el rango de anchura que
puede tener la pata de la mesa
y para eso voy a definir nuestra primera
variable que le voy a llamar a y que va
a ser el ancho de la pata de la mesa en
la pata de la mesa muy bien esta es
nuestra variable a y lo que tenemos es
que si a él le restamos 150 en realidad
estoy viendo que tanto sé qué tanto se
diferencian los 150 milímetros que yo
estoy esperando que me da el ancho y con
el ancho
final que me queda la pata ahora bien si
ya es más grande que 150 tengo que esta
diferencia es positiva ya es más chica
que 150 tengo que la diferencia es
negativa al final de cuentas yo a mí lo
que me interesa saber es la cantidad
exacta por la cual digamos se
diferencian así que basta con tomar un
valor absoluto que con esto me está
midiendo el error que cometí al hacer al
hacer la pata y este error me dice que
debe ser menor o igual que
2.5 muy bien entonces ya que tenemos
esta relación
sabemos sabemos de vídeos anteriores que
cuando tenemos un valor absoluto menor o
igual que un número esto simplemente se
traduce a que a menos 150 debe ser más
chico o igual que 2.5 y debe cumplirse
al mismo tiempo que a menos 150 sea
mayor o igual mayor o igual que menos
2.5 así que vamos a ir resolviendo esto
vamos a hacerlo simultáneo vamos a sumar
por ejemplo 150 en todos lados si lo
hacemos de forma simultánea sumamos 150
en todos lados y que es lo que me da en
la primera esto se cancela y me queda
que a debe ser menor o igual que 150 más
2.5 esos son 150 y 2.5 por otro lado me
queda de este lado que a debe ser mayor
o igual que 150 menos 2.5 y esos son 140
y 7.5 y con estas dos relaciones ya
podemos dar
porque el ancho por un lado debe ser
menor o igual que 150 y 2.5 y por otro
lado debe ser mayor o igual que 140 y
7.5 y recordemos que realmente queríamos
encontrar los valores del ancho que
podíamos tener y pues es bastante
intuitivo que sí que tenga valores entre
lo menos que puede tener y lo más que
puede tener de hecho aquí son 150 menos
2.5 que es el máximo error que podemos
tener ya que 150 más 2.5 que es también
el máximo error que tenemos hacia arriba
entonces si queremos calcular todos los
posibles valores del ancho de esta pata
basta expresar lo en términos del error
el error simplemente es el valor
absoluto de esta diferencia y no debe
pasar de 2.5 separamos en dos
desigualdades como ya habíamos visto en
vídeos anteriores realmente aquí es
tratar de entender el concepto del error
al resolver de forma simultánea estas 22
desigualdades obtenemos finalmente
nuestro rango y este es precisamente el
rango los valores van de 147.5 152
puntos 5